i would like to take this opportunity to
officially welcome you today to today's
webinar
leadership in turbulent times joining us
today
are bob sutton huggie rau and kay foster
bob sutton is a professor at management
science and engineering and professor of
organizational behavior at stanford
he co-founded the stanford technologies
ventures program
and the hassell plattner institute of
design better known as the d-school
bob received his phd in organizational
psychology from the university of
michigan
and has served as stanford faculty since
he's a senior scientist at gallup and
academic director of two executive
education programs
customer focus innovation and the
stanford innovation and entrepreneur
certificate huggy rao is an atoll mcbean
professor of organizational behavior and
human resources
graduate school of business and
professor by courtesy of sociology at
stanford university
his most recent book co-authored with
bob sutton is scaling up excellence
which is a world
a wall street journal bestseller and was
included in the best business books to
read in 2014 by financial times
inc magazine amazon forbes
washington post and the library journal
his research has been published in
numerous scientific journals and he has
served as the editor of administrative
science quarterly and has been a member
of the editorial boards of american
journal of sociology
and organization science and academic
academy of management review
the thing is is that we got these guys i
can go on and on about them they have
lots of acronyms behind their
names but i just think that they're
really solid human beings which is why
we're so excited
i'm so excited to turn this over to bob
and huggy and they're going to be
introducing our guest star
and someone we are very pleased to have
joining us today
k foster welcome
all right all right thank you robin so
uh
welcome so i'll start out and introduce
k which
we could spend the whole time
introducing k but we'll we'll get on
with the conversation
and i'll ask her a question and then
we'll get rolling and keep your
questions coming in we'd love to see
them
um okay so so kay um
first of all had a long and
distinguished and
actually complicated career as a senior
executive uh
perhaps most uh famously she was head of
hr
of johnson and johnson kind of as
there was some downsizing needing needed
so she's been in that kind of crisis
then when i first met her it seems like
about seven or eight years ago i first
met you
at uk actually in in lovely sonoma
county
she was part of an amazing top
management team at a pharmaceutical
company called onyx
that as i recall kind of you all grew it
from a half a billion dollar to a seven
billion dollar company in just a few
years which ain't easy in pharma
and then they sold it and kay's
sort of become a kind of a board member
and she's on all these boards i probably
can't remember
um all of them well she's on stanford
health board she's on spelman college's
board
she's she's chair of something called
glide memorial which is an amazing
operation
she's on a uh she's also on a private uh
company board
aggio so if i'm i'm probably
mispronouncing that and uh she also
works with boston consulting group
um advising ceos and other senior
executives
so for the first question since kay is
sort of
she's at ground central with all these
senior executives and other
companies and organizations dealing with
kovid so
it's okay what's the big advice
that you're given to those executives
you're talking to what what do you tell
them to help get them and their
organizations through these times
yeah so good morning guys and uh thanks
bob
and huggy these are uh two of my
favorite people to work with because
they're real people that's what i really
appreciate about them
so in terms of the work with ceos and
this is ceos across
all of the various platforms that i work
with whether that's philanthropic
whether that is public or private
company
and it's three things i've been telling
them the first
is really what i call this pause because
we are in this moment
where there is such an intensity around
doing something making a statement
putting yourself out there and one of
the things that i've really asked them
to do
the first thing to do is to pause and in
that pause
the way that i describe it to them we're
in this moment
of character not content and so many
companies have really made their mark
and are valued for their content
what they do i mean i use boston
consulting group as an example
we are a strategy firm we're known for
our depth of research or
rigor or analytics but like so many
other companies we are in this moment
that it's about our character it's about
who we are
how do our values actually shape the
decisions we're making
and therefore in this pause how can we
be intentional
about how we plot a path forward so the
first thing is pause
the second that and and quite frankly
i've told leaders that this to consider
this moment
this pause as a gift and if you think
about this as a gift of a pause
how would you actually best use that
gift
in service of your mission so that's the
first thing
i would say the second thing that i i
tell them and
bob you and i and huggy talked a little
bit about this how do you focus
on what's critical and
versus what's least important because
okay you will tend to do what's least
important because you you know that's
right in front of you that's the easy
stuff
how do you really get to what is
critical and how do you then
deploy and get after that so those are
the two things i start telling people
start telling my leaders to really focus
on
so let me do a follow-up question and
then honey you can jump in
so so uh i i love the two bits of advice
do you have any ideas you know this idea
of course you should focus on what's
critical not just
um other things that are sort of
distracting are there any hints that you
that or patterns that you see with
executives to
get them away from the stuff that that
is taking all their time but doesn't
matter
to get to the more important stuff
because that's one of the that that idea
of dealing with the cognitive load and
their attention is one of the hardest
things of lead
for any leader so how do you get into
the right place
yeah it's interesting and i'll give you
some examples i mean i'll do that
throughout because i think that's the
way to make this come alive
uh if i think about and i use this
example with them if i think about
9 11 i happen to be in new york
i was in new york in the city that
morning
for a follow-up visit because i for a
postnatal visit i had a four-week old
baby
and a two-year-old baby in new jersey
with my sister and i happened to be
in the city for a postnatal visit and i
was at the time i was head of hr for
uh for pfizer for a region we call jala
which was japan
asia africa middle east and latin
america so pretty broad swath of
geographies
but i was on maternity leave and to the
point of what was critical
what was interesting about pfizer we
were right in the city on 42nd street as
this unfolded
and what was interesting about pfizer
they had always said
what really mattered most to them was
the was their employees and in this
moment i saw an
organization get really clear that the
order of importance number one
was first of all finding out where their
employees were we had employees deployed
all over the world on planes we had
employees in different parts of the
country
and the first order of business was
let's locate all of our employees and
make sure they're all
safe the second order of business was
setting up a communications command
center so that as a company and that was
our headquarters we could get
information to help us understand
what was actually happening relative to
our employees and then the third
interestingly enough
then was business continuity and i think
that may surprise people that the first
thing they didn't think about was
business continuity
but it was consistent with the values of
the organization the values of the
organization was
was our people and therefore you see it
directly going towards living into those
values
so it's back to the point i made about
this is a character moment
what i say to them is what do your
values
tell you as really matters in this
moment i'll give you one other example
um fellman college i sit on the board of
spelman college and
as you could imagine in the middle of
atlanta navigating through
one of the most challenging not just
pandemics but
all of the social and racial unrest
that's related to that just crazy
an economic crisis for the college right
as a historically black college and
university and
our priority has always been excellence
in education in its broadest context
it wasn't just the academy but it was
also the experience
that these women many of them first
generation african-american women or i
should say
black women of the diaspora that
experience
of being together on campus
and really being able to have an
experience that was
all around confidence building really
making sure that we were building
whole women not just focused on the
academy
and with that as our as our priority we
started down a path of really saying
how do we move to a virtual experience
that
delivers that same level of academic
excellence in its entirety and that led
us initially to say
we would consider bringing first-year
students
physically onto campus as the only
individuals who would be on campus
and what happened over time is
our priority wasn't just or our critical
issue wasn't just about the academy
it was also to be balanced with safety
and
as the weeks progressed it became clear
that we needed and it wasn't that we
were thinking about the academy in the
absence of safety
but safety became the most critical
priority
for these women for our staff and for
all of the people who would be caring
for them
because of the way in which the pandemic
was unfolding
in atlanta and i think that's the other
learning i tell them
it's not that you're straying from what
matters but you've got to be
adaptable and flexible and be able to
pivot where necessary so
make a long story short we've now
pivoted and we just announced that
spelman that we will be completely
virtual
for all attendees in the fall
and that's a tough i can tell you that
is a very difficult decision
to make as an as an academic institution
where so much
of what we deliver our value proposition
is about that in person experience
that's tough that's beautifully
described
okay thank you again for being here and
for sharing your wisdom
i'm still thinking about your wonderful
point about
making a pause or pausing
and the reason i'm fascinated by that is
most people when they think of crisis
they think
the thing you need to do is respond very
fast and very quickly
and what i hear your advice is hey
don't go fast cause reflect
i i find that wonderfully
counter-intuitive
now listening to you one and
particularly as you talked about
the rich example of spelman college
it seems to me that people try and
simplify crises
is there a sensible thing to do how
would you
provide ramps to people for them to
understand
hey this crisis is a little more complex
and you want to improve their
understanding but not overwhelm their
capacity
how do you reconcile capacity on the one
hand
with what the organization ought to do
can you
you know share with us some examples of
that please
yeah it's interesting because your point
about the
the the tendency to want to move fast
this sense of
urgency one point i'll make about that
is i've talked
in this moment with leaders about
compassionate urgency
so i am not suggesting that you not act
with
urgency but you see we have made urgency
equivalent to speed and for me
you can absolutely act with
compassionate urgency because it means
you
absolutely have a sense of urgency in
that cause
you are really making sure that you are
what is the right order to take those
steps in and
any system that you are leading are you
bringing the appropriate
level of care and attention to that
system so i talk about compassionate
urgency i'm not asking people
to not act with the appropriate sense of
urgency but urgency doesn't mean speed
for me
urgency is about deliberation it's about
this sense of compassion
and it's about the sense of being
thoughtful
about how you move forward so i don't
um again i want to make sure that people
don't hear
that i'm not suggesting you move with
you don't move with urgency but that you
absolutely move with urgency
your second point about capacity
i use the word capacity as opposed to
capability
and i'll tell you why because in this
moment the tendency is
let's just throw more people at the
problem right
less if we just had more people if we
just kind of attacked it full-on
and one of the things that i have been
suggesting
both within companies as well as on
board is to really on boards is to focus
on capacity so i'll give you the example
of
boards and then i'll give you the
example of organization so on boards
one of the things that i have been and
my colleagues have been doing
is we have been working to increase the
capacity
of the organizations that we serve by
bringing
our own expertise we've said to those
for instance
the college presidents or to the ceos
use us as resources we've been through
crises before
we actually have uh networks and we
can actually supplement and increase
your capacity
without you having to feel like you have
to take it on your own and i think this
is a really
important moment for board members to
really be leaning
in and helping in increase the capacity
of uh the organizations they're aligned
with
with respect to organizations um it's a
little bit of
turning the pyramid on its head moving
from
this strong need and this sense of
control because again to your
point in the midst of all of this
uncertainty complexity chaos
what you want to do as a leader you you
tend to want to control
and to narrow the the degrees of control
what i've suggested
is you really turn that pyramid on its
head and move to a more distributed
model of leadership
and really use this as an opportunity in
a remote setting
and where you are virtual how do you
empower
the individuals in the organization
because a lot of the either innovation
solution a lot of that is going to
bubble up from within the organization i
see it real time
in a lot of the you know or our
millennial generation is a generation
that understands connectivity
communication in a virtual world better
than
anyone that i know so the ability
to really ask them it's like leaders
i've been with some leaders who've been
wrestling with
culture how do you create connection and
how do you reinforce and
continue to strengthen culture and
engagement
in a remote or in a virtual environment
and what i've suggested to them is ask
people who know how to do this
you know my daughter for instance who
has been at home since march in a remote
environment from college
she is more connected than ever to her
friends and they've figured out a way i
walked in one day and they were
they've found an entire apartment and
and
leased it and figured i mean they did
everything virtually and i walked in one
day and there were six of them having a
conversation they've distributed
out the tasks that everybody has
accountability for all of that was then
worked well
so you know this is my point about
really
embracing you know not just talking
about distributed leadership
but really embracing it in this moment
hmm
i i really love uh what you're saying
okay about
distributed leadership and this example
of your daughter of course is
uh you know striking and indeed
illuminating
i will i was wanting to ask you a
question about two things
that are in my mind now one is what you
said was
character the other is capacity
they're the two c's the third c of
course is crises
if you will so can you share with us
why is it some companies
have a character and capacity level
that gets them to respond to crises as
threats
and other companies say actually you
know what the crisis is an opportunity
what is it about their character and
their capacity that allows them to see
the opportunity side of the crisis
yeah this might sound like a pat answer
but it's about leadership i mean that's
the thing
that repeatedly i have seen if you ask
me thematically what i've seen in this
moment
it's all of the things that you know we
learn in school that you guys teach in
the academy
it's real leadership and i mean i make
the distinction between
leadership with a big l which is all the
things that you learn which is my title
which is the hierarchy and small l
which is really understanding that the
solutions
don't come from a small concentrated
group of individuals who are the experts
right
that expertise actually again like
leadership
is distributed across the organization
and i think this idea of even
thinking about uh to your point thinking
about
character and capacity as ways to
as levers for unlocking innovation
you get that coming up through the
organization not just because the ceo
you know had a brilliance broke spoke of
genius and i think that that
this moment is just such a moment for
us to be thinking about
who are we in terms of our leadership
are we truly distributed if i am in this
organization
do i really understand what leadership
in this moment means
i'm going to connect it to diversity as
well
because we couldn't have this
conversation without talking about
diversity equity and inclusion
and yesterday i was talking with
uh i was talking with uh with a client
and making the point that
the reason to have diverse points of
view
or diverse individuals is because their
lived experience creates with them
a context that is different than the
prevailing context
so for me when i think about diversity
and inclusion
i'm not thinking about checking the
boxes i'm really thinking
uh that gives me access to
insights to understandings that i
just don't have and i mean if you want
to then convert that into a commercial
opportunity
absolutely that's not where i start you
know i give you the example of onyx bob
you talked about onyx when i started to
work with uh dr tony coles who was the
ceo
there we had a conversation about
diversity and he said
uh diversity for him was not about
a scorecard that was solely full
of representation he said here's the
premise we are trying to do something
that is incredibly difficult there
haven't been any
novel therapies in this particular
area in 30 years and therefore
we need the brightest most innovative
most
creative thinkers to be able to help us
solve this
issue so unless uk believe
that a completely homogeneous group of
individuals
reflect the brightest the best and the
most innovative thinkers on the planet
you have to have we have to have a
diverse organization and i will tell you
with that
fundamental uh premise for how to
approach
building an organization we ended up and
i was it was one of the most diverse
leadership teams i've ever been a part
of
and it was one of the most diverse
organizations i've ever built
and it was because we started with the
premise
as opposed to starting with a set of
metrics or outcomes that we wanted
so just to to reinforce k's point i
remember
seven or eight years ago in sonoma
walking downstairs and i actually hadn't
looked at pictures of the top team
and so so and i've dealt with a lot of
top teams and they are
the ones i deal with honestly are 90 um
male usually and especially white male
so i walk downstairs
black ceo k's black and uh half men
half women half born in the united
states half not
and then i talked to somebody who i
missed the cfo
and he started talking about his husband
he was a one of the few white males on
the
board and you guys just did great in
that company
so it's okay there's a number of
questions coming in
and and there's something that that that
i want to ask about because
at least for me this is a moment that
right now this is what i'm hearing from
the organizations and leaders i'm
working with in fact
uh recently i had a conversation with
somebody who i think used to work for
you
and he described how on his fast growing
company
so he's now on the top management team
he wasn't on the top management team in
those days
that um he they all are so stressed
that he sent out an email about a
presentation at midnight
and he got back two long responses at
midnight
and he said he realized that something
is wrong
so what are you saying with all because
it's a really tough time every leader i
know
is just beleaguered what are you saying
to them about how they take care of
themselves and take care of their people
for what seemed like a short crisis but
now it seems to be a way of life
what are you saying yeah yeah a couple
of things
so um you know i i i
start by talking to them about caring
for yourself so you can care for others
the old adage
but with people who are incredibly
motivated who are incredibly focused on
getting things done i ask them to
approach care of self the same way and i
use myself as an example
so i'm i i you know
i actually have a very structured
approach to caring for myself because i
place that
with the same value i do as
the rigor that i bring to advising
clients the rigor that i bring to
anything i bring that same level of
rigor so i have a series of practices
that i actually use everything starting
with
you know i i literally calendar
what time does my alarm go off what time
do i get when the first thing i do in
the morning
is really care for a set of practices
that i know are important to feeding me
so there's prayer there's meditation
there's some stretches there's really
getting my head ready for the day
and i have also in this moment and i
learned it the hard way because when we
first went to zoom i would be on these
12 to 14 hour zoom
days and i just said to myself who am i
in that moment right and how can i
coach others or advise others when i was
living
out of integrity with what i was telling
others so i
i took a step back and really said okay
i open up my office between
7 30 and 8 o'clock are there times when
i'm going to have to do something that
flexes maybe because a european team or
a team in asia asks for
an exception yes but i'm really clear
about how i structure my day i wear a
device i won't call the name because i'm
not advertising for anybody but i wear a
device
that reminds me to get up and move
because it's also important for us to
move
you see that i'm standing i have a
standing desk
and i'm standing because that also is
part of keeping my system whole and then
in the evening
i actually literally close my office
door between 5 30 and 6 and i turn off
and again for my council to them is
you've got to figure
out what works for you but you can
for two reasons number one your energy
is not
inexhaustible that that just is not the
case and then the second
is it's the role model that you are
setting
for the organization in the way that you
are adapting and then the last thing i
tell them is it's about being in
integrity so as a ceo i have one of my
ceos who was talking about the fact that
uh flexibility mattered it was really
key
for recognizing that you know people who
had caregiver responsibilities and when
i say caregiver responsibilities
that's not just children and maybe
parents
that's animals that you may have to care
for so
and he would say you know people who
have caregiver responsibilities really
important to recognize that be flexible
but he was still sending emails and
expecting responses
you know at all hours of the night and
my counsel to him was
even if you feel compelled to write an
email
like put it in draft you know send it
the next morning so
and that doesn't mean that because we
are in a crisis there aren't going to be
times when you've got to be all
on but i learned this lesson at johnson
and johnson we ended up acquiring a
company
called the corporate athlete and the
principle was based on the fact that
executives are just like athletes and if
you
look at how athletes stay ready
they do a couple of things one is they
focus on
food as fuel so there's a component
around nutrition
they focus on movement because you know
even
when they're not on the court or not in
in actually in game settings they're
still focusing on movement
and then the third is either some form
of
reflection that could be prayer that
could be meditation that could be
chanting
but it's the recognition that that's how
you know
talk to your athletes care for
themselves to make them to ensure that
they're always game ready that's what
i'm telling my ceos and the last thing
i'll say is i tell them
you vote with your time and your money
so if you
show me your calendar and your checkbook
i can tell you what you actually value
not what you say
brilliant i love this they've been i've
been watching the chat as
was bob and they've been a number of
questions and i thought i'd
sort of bring up two of them that
i'm sure our viewers would love to know
particularly given your
spread of global experience and the fact
that you're involved in so many
industries
so the question that's being asked is
is managing crises a one-size-fits-all
approach
or do you have to change from country to
country
the question was in the developing world
a related question is
and i think this was prompted perhaps by
your spelman discussion
does the do the ways in which you manage
a crisis
change from industry to industry so
country to country
industry to industry what's your what
are your views on that game
yeah i mean i i think there are some
core
principles that are consistent across
the board
but there are the nuances that happen
let's pick country at a country level i
remember
being uh you know as i mentioned i had
part of my remit when i was head of hr
for that broad geography
part of my remit was uh asia and part of
the
one of the countries that we had a very
profitable business in was indonesia
so i spent a lot of time on the ground
in indonesia
in the midst of fires and riots and
turmoil
and in many instances people would say
that what that absolutely was a crisis
and
we again led with the same kind of
principles under 9 11. the first thing
was
you know the safety of our employees and
again
the way in which you execute that at a
local level may be different you know in
on the pfizer in new york we actually
had the capability of understanding
where our employees were
even though we didn't have obviously the
the kind of technology we have today we
had better access to understanding that
because you know for people who were
traveling for instance we had
a corporate travel office and they kept
track of all of our
employees wherever they were if they
were on a plane or if they were in a
country outside
of their home country so we had an
easier way of
doing that in indonesia that was very
much more of a
content i remember actually being in the
office when we sent everybody out in the
parking lot
and we literally counted everybody so so
again
the premise is still the same we start
with protecting our employees
the second was communication and you
know
you remember the example i gave in in
pfizer in new york
where we wanted to ensure getting
communication
in through all the channels we could and
then getting that back out to employees
in indonesia same premise it was just
executed differently
and then with respect to business
continuity it also was
how do we make sure that this disruption
these riots that are happening around us
what do we need to do
to protect our assets so it's the
principles i would say are generally the
same
it's the execution of those principles
and then the last thing i would say with
respect to crises is
it's really important to be adaptable
because particularly in dynamic
environments
you can even though you may have set the
course
you have to be willing and able to adapt
because you don't always
you're not always in control of the
context in which you're operating
lovely one quick follow-up from one of
our viewers
the questioner or the participant in our
webinar
works for a very traditional company
where the management believes in control
and so the question this person is
posing to all of us is
hey the leadership in my company loves
to control things but we
at the bottom levels of the organization
see enormous possibilities
what do we know we need to do to
persuade our leadership
to listen to us i think is the question
that's being posed
so i won't be facetious because if i
were facetious i would say call me i
probably have a job for you but
will answer seriously um look
one of the one of the unlocks that i've
found in these moments
is actually come up with us with a
specific idea
right and uh let me give you an example
so i was talking yesterday
with a client and one of the employees
was talking about
even the the way to think about the
company it's an insurance company and
there was this
concept that they they actually ensure
mobile phones for instance and
one of the conversations we were having
was about diversity and i said
here's an interesting idea uh if
the if my phone right as a as a black
mother of black children my phone
the phone that my children have is a
lifeline
it isn't just about making calls it's
because when they leave home
i know that that is a way that they can
contact me if they're stopped by by the
authorities
if they break down along the side of the
road whatever
is the dynamic that's happening so that
phone
is not just to make calls or to text
that phone is actually a lifeline and if
you're an insurer
who you know you ensure you know
to make sure that phones when they're
broken they're quickly repaired
that the insurance that you're providing
is on par with life insurance right
and the only reason that you would know
that for instance is because you have
employees of color in your organization
who can provide that dynamic to you
so we have that conversation that came
up
from the bottom of the organization not
from the top so i think the more you can
be
specific about the opportunity or the
idea
the better it will be because i do think
they are and that's my point about
turning the pyramid on its head
the the the amount of innovation and
insight and ideas that i see manifesting
coming up through the organization is
really
really uh for me at this point in time
it's one of the things that's giving me
a lot of optimism
because you know we we so often have
bought into this hierarchical
way of thinking about leadership it's
why i make the distinction between
l big l and small l small algorithms
that we have
we now have in an organization i don't
know if you have 500 people in the
organization
they're not five people that are on the
hook for for for delivering great ideas
you now have all of these minds and
you've said to them
you know we want to liberate you and i
know how hard it can be particularly on
the point around control
one of the ceos i'm working with uh
has has really struggled with
uh uh remote work with uh
virtual because he is still a ceo
that believes in facetime uh you know i
want to physically see people
i want to check the parking lot are
people still in our car still in the
parking lot or five o'clock in the
afternoon
and really coaching him through how can
you be
in first of all inquire from yourself
why you still are focusing on control
because if it's contr if control
means that you don't trust the people
you have
maybe you should fire all the people you
have again i'm not trying to be
positions but these are the questions
that i
asked them because i think what happens
so often we don't get to the beliefs i
spend time with them asking them
what is the underlying belief behind
control
what's your insight about why control
matters so much to you
and you know it's unpacking that that
creates some access
for some of the folks and then i
encourage them to do experiments
you know have a small don't do something
it's not going to break the bank it's
not going to blow the company up and it
may actually be an opportunity
bring a group of people together and
tell them to share the best idea that
they have
um you know in organizations that are
not as open to that
experimentation might be a way of doing
that
i love that
bob i think we've lost your audio sorry
is that is it back yeah yes i think it's
back yeah yeah so anyways
i just hit my mute button so um just to
comment
just a few months ago we were in
conversations with an organization that
came to stanford they wanted to be more
innovative
and they described themselves as an
organization where everybody wore
suits and ties or the female equivalent
you had to be at your desk wearing a
white shirt by the way for a man
at 7 30 in the morning and you left at
five
and that's how that so i really wonder
how they're dealing with kovid
because because we were sort of like uh
i i think you've got
you're mistaking control for creativity
okay
so so so here's a question and this this
is a hard question
so so this question is i work for an
organization
with a management team that is white and
asian when i brought up the fact that
our team does not reflect the community
we serve
i was told to focus on diversified
diversifying direct service staff
what's your what's your comment on that
well and advice yeah um
you know so so no surprise to you bob
that is not the first time that i've
heard that i've heard something like
that
that person might even be my client
so what did you tell your client yeah
look
um you know i i i'm big on storytelling
because i think storytelling using
my story or my experience creates an
opening and an access for connection
right because so much of this work is
so much of the inability for others to
see
them to see themselves and others that
distance so even that example you gave
that that management team there's no way
that that management team was able to
see themselves
in that individual the distance between
whether that was structural distance
or whether that was ideological distance
but the distance between them and this
individual
was you know they couldn't even
understand why why that individual was
asking that question
so my counsel to the person or at least
i'll start with the person then i'll
start with the management team even
though they've neither asked for
nor may not appreciate my counsel
but for the individual i think these are
also moments where
you know you've got to make some really
tough decisions do you want to stay in
the game
and do you want to continue to come
forward from a place of solutions and i
really
urge people in this space of diversity
equity and inclusion particularly
um to really come forward with solutions
or with
recommendations or suggestions because i
think what happens
is we point out the deficiency we say
the management team isn't diverse enough
or we say that our company isn't diverse
enough and what i
help some teams to do is
get real about why does it matter so it
could be that you've decided it's a
moral
imperative or you could say you know
there are significant
opportunities that we are missing as a
team that we need to be focusing on i'll
give you a couple of examples
because one of the things i hear a lot
of the time is
our industry our company is not customer
focused
right it's not customer facing so
obviously diversity matters because if
you
have uh you know if you have a growing
demographic
that is asian black
latinx that you need to
be able to access that you want to
respond to or connect with
then of course you are going to you know
see a closer
way of you know diversity having an
impact on your
business and i use the p i use the
example of biotech i use the example of
pharmaceuticals
why do farm why should pharmaceutical
companies apart from just the point i
made earlier
about innovation and about the
perspective and lived experience
actually around problem solving that's
well documented
i go back to how pharmaceutical and
biotech drugs get developed we have
clinical trials right
and clinical trials historically
have been populated with a phenotype
that is not diverse
and one of the things that i have argued
and i continue to push for
is including individuals with
different genetic makeup individuals
with
different ethnicities because it
increases not just the absolute
population of individuals you can now
access
because there's so many more people on
the planet
so your ability to enroll faster
and get those clinical trials to through
the various phases of development faster
that's one piece the second
is the insight the scientific insight
and discovery
that you can get access to now because
you're not looking at a monolithic
population so for me that's on the front
end and then on the back end is the
ability to serve historically
underserved populations
so it's a complete integrated solution
particularly for biotech and healthcare
companies
diversity isn't just about checking the
boxes diversity is
fundamentally about how you can create
greater value for yourself and for
patients
right that's wonderful okay
there have been so many questions coming
up from your comments
like when you offer examples and make
observations
there's so many ramps that people are
getting onto to ask questions
and there was one question that sort of
struck me and this had to do with
the impostor syndrome so the question is
how do you lead people you suspect have
an impostor syndrome
and as a person of color overcoming
impostor syndrome as well
yeah so look i i am a firm believer that
um using my story uh and i i
i'm on my own journey like we all are
and
you know there absolutely uh have been
and will probably continue to be points
in my journey where
that is that's what encompasses me
and i will tell you that at various
points in time particularly so
just for context most of my career
professional career up until just before
onyx
i was either the only person of color
the only woman and sometimes the only
per
the only woman of color as a matter of
fact a little pejoratively i was
in lynn massachusetts i spent about six
months in lynn massachusetts
uh and one of my uh one of my client one
of my uh
jobs when i was uh head of a when i was
an hr business partner
and i would say that in order to see
another
person of color i had to go into the
bathroom and look in the mirror
and uh you know so
so i use that as context to say that
there were moments in time
when i really questioned you know
my why am i here you know is it
is it you know people are gonna find out
i i'm only here because whatever reason
people are gonna find out that
you know all this this persona is not
real
that underneath all of this is all of
these vulnerabilities and all of those
things are going to come to the fore
and one of the things that became really
important and i continue to use it now
and i always encourage people to do that
surround yourself with people
that actually not validate you but
people that you can
check in with when you have those
moments that is part of the human
condition
right unless you are some sort of uh
you have some sort of uh psychological
disorder that causes you not to have any
humility hubris whatsoever and and i do
know some of those people some of them
are my clients but
um i i do think it's important to
surround yourself or at least have
touch points with people that help you
when you
are in those moments and it's not about
validating you but it's really
an inquiry with you what's what's
causing that to come
up is there something about this
particular situation that you are
in that has caused that to happen when
have you been in
similar situations and for me it's
sometimes it's reminding myself
i lived through and uh led through
9 11 i lived through and led through
i lived and led through the riots in in
indonesia
you know just reminding myself of those
touch points
that when that comes up that you know
there
is there is something solid about who i
am and what i have to offer and
practicing
not just having people help you with
that but practicing
that self-talk yourself is really really
important i'm teaching that to my kids
as well
because as you can imagine as young
black i have a young black male
son if he took in
all of the you know perceptions
that are prevalent around being a young
black male in america
that can have i call those micro uh
micro traumas
that ultimately could really do a number
on him so how do i help him
when he goes through these books ask
those questions who are you talking with
who is inquiring what what is coming up
and really starting to understand
where are those patterns what's
happening in those moments
that's causing you and is it a
particular uh circumstance for me
i went through understanding when am i
triggered that way
right and i just i used to call it
suffer from the expert syndrome
i believe that anything i did i had to
be not just a functional but a technical
expert
and with time i came to realize
that when i was asked to be part of
something i wasn't
asked for to be a technical expert i'm
not a scientist i'm not a physician
what i know really really well and i
continue to study
is leadership people organizations
culture and that that's my sweet spot
and i continue to be open to learning in
that sweet spot
that's some of the stuff that helps
unpack
when i find myself going down that path
but i want to reassure the person that
doesn't go away because you've arrived
or
achieved something that's a part of the
human condition
yeah i love your candor and thank you
for sharing that
experience as well as i listen to you
and i'm sure some of our
viewers also resonated with this
it's almost as though you're saying look
the real key is curiosity
and the more curious you are the more
questions you ask
the more liberating it is which brings
me to a question
i also realize we're at 10 48
and that is
in leading in turbulent times should
organizations invest in the capacity to
expect the unexpected
and if so how and that's a
good question so i would say i love that
question because
it's not in turbulent times right when i
sit on boards or when i
advise i'm actually asking and it's
interesting i was thinking about this
this morning
i'm asking about what's your business
continuity plan
how well do you understand the risk of
the business and i'm not asking that
because we're in covet
i'm asking that in times of
quote-unquote stability and prosperity
because if you wait until covet you
don't
have the distance you don't have the
time
you don't have the flexibility and
adaptive adaptability
you're just reacting as opposed to you
know
business continuity i look at that
through the lens of enterprise risk
management
and when i talk about enterprise risk
management for even public or
privately traded companies as you know
there's always the focus
on financial risk you know we have the
audit committee we have the outside
auditors
what i've been pushing to successfully
so far
to expand the definition of enterprise
risk to include
culture talent and leadership so every
board that i'm
on that is what i'm asking and it either
that then becomes part of the audit
committee or it becomes part of what
used to be the compensation committee
but i'm
really pushing that because to me those
are fundamental risks to the enterprise
it
isn't just about the financial risk but
it's about the culture
it's about the talent it's the
leadership and recognizing that
not just in stable times those things
are critical
but they're even more critical now think
about the environment we're in right now
so i am actually
pushing for that the last thing i'll say
i'm also encouraging that
individually and personally right
because
right now we find you know we're now
thinking about those things
in this moment and what triggered it is
a good friend of mine yesterday
sent me uh some she's some person who
lives on her own
and she sent me her continuity plan
for in the event something happens to
her
she lives on her own and in the event
she's on her own here are the detailed
instructions here's the numbers of who
to call
and that's for for me that's not morbid
that's the same degree of preparation
and
you know there's the financial component
to it there is the familial component
to it who who in your family you know so
i think it's so
important that's one thing that this
particular set of crises because we talk
about crisis
but we have an economic crisis
we have a pandemic so health crisis
and we are in the midst of part of uh in
our history as a nation
one of the most divisive politically
divisive uh
times in our history so in and in a
very short time we are in an election
cycle
so we have for all intents and purposes
it's the confluence
of all of those things that's creating a
level of complexity because they're
all interrelated there's no serial way
or individual let me address this first
address that next
right what i see i've told you on uh you
and bob i say
aspire for linear plan for circuitous
and discontinuous
right right so so
so you pretend that life is orderly but
you got to deal with the daily mess
that's what you just said
absolutely
that's leadership i love this leadership
with a small
l yes so we've got five minutes huggie
what
what are interesting questions what
strikes you
one thing i'd love the readers to walk
away with is
our viewers of course know that kay is
an extraordinarily accomplished person
who carries
her accomplishments so lightly on her
shoulders
but the thing that has struck both bob
and i about cain that's why
we admire her is how much time and
effort she invests
in self-improvement in learning
and it's like a continual thing and you
know if it's okay with uk
i'd love for you to share with the
listeners here
your strategies to learn where i was
like amazed when you told me some time
ago that
you pick one word and then you spend a
lot of time
just trying to understand that word can
you give us an example of a word like
that
so so let me share with you where that
comes from because i think that will mat
that will that will shed some light so i
as both you and bob know i grew up in
the caribbean i grew up in barbados and
i was there until i was 19.
that that that intellectual curiosity
that hunger for learning comes from my
mother
my mother was one of eight children
uh she was the eldest and a female
and at the time she was taken out of
school to help my grandmother raise her
brothers
and my mother from a very early age
instilled in us the value of education
and curiosity
and so this focus on continual learning
and my mother up until she died last
year and up until the time she died she
there was always a book my mother was
reading and it wasn't just the bible
my mother was constantly reading she
would read with a dictionary next to her
and it was i think a lot of this
i have really um she instilled that in
me
and i saw here is some person who didn't
finish the equivalent of high school
but i consider one of the
you know i consider her to be one of the
brightest people that i know because of
that
interest and that curiosity that she
always had
not just through book learning as she
would call it
but just about the world and you know we
don't have time but there's so many
sayings
that my mother instilled in me that i
draw on
and you know you know the words it's
interesting my daughter's doing the same
thing i'm in my office and i have a
white board
and every day i put a different word
down
and at the end of the week i think about
okay what did i learn about that word
and what does that word mean and where
am i seeing it
and it's everything for i mean sometimes
they're like
you know really significant words my
daughter put up like
la location and i was like huh
where did you ever read that in a book
it's something that uh that that i find
for me and i
really encourage people to find what you
are curious about whatever it is that
you're curious about
i'm curious about reading and about
learning and self-improvement
what are you curious about and let that
be the thing
that causes you every day to commit
yourself
to being a little bit more curious about
the world right
that that that's what i would ask people
to do
fabulous so okay we've got one minute
and and then robin's gonna um take it
away so
um first of all we want to thank you for
just as usual you're
sort of rambunctious traveling wonderful
self
so so in the final kind of minute here
sort of backing up in this crazy
pandemic we're from if you were going to
say
what surprised you the most in a good
way
in the last few months so let's say
another positive note
yeah yeah what surprised me most
is the the uncommon generosity of people
and i see it
in big ways and i see it in small ways
i'll give you just a small example out
here in my neighborhood
we got on the neighborhood app and all
of our neighbors committed
every day to purchase meals from our
local restaurants
to keep them going if you they said if
you
are a small uh you know if you're a
small family
you can't do that buy a gift card so so
this i mean simple things like that we
have a we have a lending library
that started as books it now has food it
has flowers
and it's just anybody in the
neighborhood can just go and pick up or
drop off
so the uncommon generosity of of
individuals
and that's what i focus on i really
focus on that
that's beautiful robin
thank you so much kay it was just
wonderful
um as i said i always enjoy the two of
you
here i am popping back up that was
just a fabulous way to spend an hour i
want to thank all three of you for that
kay thank you so much for joining us
bob and huggy as always what a pleasure
thank you everyone who's watching and
submitted so many great questions
like that that was a really nice
questions are great
yes thank you so much and i want to
remind everyone that we are going to be
send a recording of this
out within one week and so if you're
here and you've registered then you're
going to get that recording and with
that
sunny california signing off thanks
everyone for coming thanks robin for
making this happen
thank you so much to be safe
thank you again
you